[موسيقى]
تزداد سخونه الجبهه الشماليه يوما بعد اخر
مع ارتفاع مستوى الضربات المتبادله بين
الجيش الاسرائيلي من جهه وحزب الله
اللبناني ومقاتلين من كتائب القسام وسرايا
القدس من جهه اخرى رغم اقتصارها في
البدايه على مناوشات انحصرت في منطقه شبعا
ومزارعها اذ شهدت الساعات الماضيات تطورا
في عدد الهجمات التي اعلن حزب الله
اللبناني انه نفذها ضد مواقع اسرائيليه
على طول الخط الحدودي فضلا عن استهدافه
قوه للجيش الاسرائيلي في منطقه شتوه
بالجليل الاعلى ودبابه من طراز مركاب في
موقع الراهب الحدودي الجيش الاسرائيلي
سارع باعلان بلدات حدوديه مع لبنان منطقه
عسكريه مغلقه واكد رده على مصادر اطلاق
النيران وقصفه مناطق في محيط بلدتي راميا
وعيتا الشعب في جنوب لبنان وان طائراته
تواصل استهداف البنيه التحتيه العسكريه
لحزب الله وكان العاشر من اكتوبر الجاري
قد شهد بدايه دخول الجبهه الشماليه على خط
عمليه طوفان الاقصى حين اعلنت سرايا القدس
تنفيذ عدد من مقاتليها عمليه تسلل الى
الجليل الغربي واشتباكه مع جنود
اسرائيليين موقعه فيهم قتلى وجرحى لاحقا
شنت مروحيات اسرائيليه غارات داخل الاراضي
اللبنانيه استهدفت مواقع لحزب الله قرب
بلدات يارين والظهير وعيت الشعب اسفرت عن
مقتل ثلاثه من مقاتلي الحزب الذي رد لاحقا
باستهداف اليه عسكريه اسرائيليه في
مستوطنه افيفيم في حين نعت كتائب القسام
للمره الاولى ثلاثه من مقاتليها من خارج
الاراضي الفلسطينيه قالت انهم تمكنوا من
تفجير السياج الحدودي والتسلل قرب مستوطنه
مرجلي في اصبع الجليل واشتبكوا مع قوه
اسرائيليه واوقع فيها خسائر قبل ان تتدخل
مروحيات اسرائيليه وتستهدف
y